I had a pencil in my hand all at my life
and enjoyed drawing and decided i was
going to be an architect and when I was
at Santa Monica College I I worked for
my father one summer vacation who was in
our director and did some drawings
actual drawing so when I get out he kept
saying you know before you go to use
aircraft yacht I gotta call Fox and see
if they need an apprentice and I said
that's not me anymore you know it's and
he says well you know you gotta take a
shot at it and I didn't but I got a
phone call from a chief draftsman at Fox
and he said he was looking for an
apprentice I said that my father call
you he said known all the boys in the
drafting room he said but come and he
says if you have any drawings you know
that helped so I interviewed and he said
Lee make me an apprentice draftsman so I
started in the art department 1955 as a
Prentice and three months later he made
me a junior and and I kept you know
going up the ladder and by 1958 I was
made an assistant art director and
I went on picture the greatest story
ever told with Richard day and all the
way through the picture I was always
very close and invited to be you know
involved in the middle of the picture
mr. de quit and he Stevens asked me to
finish the picture and I of course had
to talk to my boss and he said don't
worry about him he he was through it was
more than he could handle he says but he
says if you take this job